[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the guardian
columnist zoe williams and the deputy
editor of conservative home henry hill
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the times front page leads with a story
on how liz truss has won the support of
suella braverman in the tory leadership
campaign after the foreign secretary's
allies made a series of highly personal
attacks on penny mordent
the eye points out that penny mordant's
status as a favorite in the tory
leadership race has prompted her rivals
to criticize her ahead of tv debates in
the next few days
the metro reacts to a strong showing on
the second ballot by the former defence
secretary their headline pennies in
heaven
the telegraph hears that the former
chief brexit negotiator lord frost is
urging kemi badanock to stand aside so
liz trust can have a clear run into the
final two
the mirror warns temperatures could hit
40 degrees next week
the guardian reports that the
environment agency is calling for water
company bosses to be jailed over serious
pollution levels and for breaching
environmental laws
the ft has the latest on the fortunes of
the american investment banks morgan
stanley and jp morgan
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by zoe
williams and henry hill welcome to you
both good to see you let's start with
the i and they're suggesting that uh
penny mordant is now the favorite the
headline tory rival's turn on mordent as
favorite faces
tv trial zoe
i mean
it to me it demonstrates how thin the
contest is because the truth of it is
penny morden
she's not she it's it's not as though
she's been kind of fighting her time in
the desert waiting to have all these
kind of amazing ideas and spring forward
with a with a real hinterland and a kind
of new conservative platform
her her kind of past is very very thin
her career before parliament is very
thin her career within parliament is
very thin it's not an accident that
david frost has been able to say these
things about her such that you know
whenever you look for her and she's
doing a job she's never there
most people who
think the same thing
so really what we're looking at is
somebody who's
benefiting from a lack of recognition
to kind of spring forward as the
non-continuity candidate and a lot of
members and indeed a lot of commentators
are responding to the non-continuity
candidate they're like oh well it would
be great to not have continuity because
continuity has been terrible um i think
she probably will come unstuck
if not before she becomes the leader
then certainly soon after because she's
she she is not a heavyweight
henry do you agree with that analysis um
a finn career the newspaper is actually
saying that she would beat sunak amongst
the the public that's according to
polling
yeah i think the the the thing that's
really given her campaign a turbo boost
is the fact that the all of the polling
available i think well not all of it but
certainly conservative homes survey and
the hugo polling suggests that she will
absolutely walk any final head-to-head
between herself and another challenger
with conservative party members and of
course that sort of winning power has an
attractiveness all of its own but it is
true that we don't really know what sort
of conservatism penny morgan stands for
a few weeks ago you might have said that
she was more towards the left liberal
end on many social issues but she's been
rather friendly rowing that back
in order to try and cement her place in
the race i think the challenge for her
is
what's her path to the final two if you
add up though the right-wing votes which
is broadly speaking the sowella bravoman
kimmy badnot liz truss votes that gets
you to about 140. that's enough for a
place in the final i think that she's
going to struggle to peel many of those
off that leaves you with the other path
which is rishi sunak now again rishi
sunak not doing as well as he'd opposed
definitely one of the weakest first
place showings in modern conservative
history in terms of the first round vote
but nonetheless he's 20 votes ahead of
her he's over a hundred i think the way
that she gets through to the final two
if she does is that sunac supporters
look at this fairly woeful set of polls
for him on the second round conclude
that he might actually lose to this
truss and then transfer to him or mass
uh in order to put pay any penny in
instead
uh and
zoe do you think that um perhaps not as
high figure as uh the tsunac campaign
were wishing for 101 up 13 but he he
would have hoped to have been at least
sort of around 120 do you think that
bodes extremely well
for penny mordent
i mean i think the
tsunak got high on his own supply in a
way he felt like because he was so well
connected and so well prepared and so
well-funded
that he was going to walk it and he
really hadn't done due diligence on how
he was seen in the party and how he was
seen in the in the wider membership and
that isn't
it doesn't vote brilliantly for his
political acumen
but
you know which of us could say that any
of their political acumen is amazing i
mean i genuinely think penny morden is
benefiting from
not having any real hinterland
recognition or
base i think she's really benefiting
from that because people are saying well
you know anything other than this and
she hasn't really got any associations
but
i i mean i would be surprised if
the party i mean i really take harry's
point that she could peel off sunax
supporters and end up in the finals too
and then she would walk it but i would
be really surprised if the
mps
made such a shallow decision
henry what about uh suella braverman's
um she's come out for for liz trust but
uh her supporters might not necessarily
follow suit
no i mean no nobody commands the votes
that they win
as a block
they can encourage them to vote a
certain way but they can't command them
to do it so most of them may transfer to
list trust she does seem after a
slightly shaky start to be consolidating
that vote but
some of them may go to kemi badlock
who's who's had a remarkably good
campaign really for somebody who's never
been in cabinet uh is still in the race
had a very good launch i don't really
see at this point how she can get over
the top it's a decision seems to have
been made by the senior euro skeptics
that liz is going to be their candidate
i'm not entirely sure that they they
might not come to to regret that in time
but we'll see but
sowell is out she will fall in she was
the most right-wing candidate running
she'll fall in behind liz trust and i
think that would be a welcome shot in
the arm
to liz who has really been
underperforming compared to expectations
i don't really think at the start of
this competition that she would expect
to be running in third place and there
to be serious questions about whether or
not she'll even make the final two
and why do you think that is zoe that
she isn't in third place i mean her name
had been mentioned many times before
months before as a possible candidate
for prime minister
i mean i would situate this in three
ways firstly it wasn't a great idea for
her to be out of the country when the
whole thing kicked off i mean i think
she might she may have made the
calculation that it was great not to get
your hands dirty or as boris johnson
said dip your hands in blood but
it did mean that she just wasn't in the
fray and that does count
secondly i think the thatcher cosplay i
don't know how it plays in conservative
home and i would be fascinated to learn
but i very much doubt with mps and
certainly not with anyone else that
jumping up in these kind of variations
of market capture poses with her
ridiculous fur hats and
had walled gardens and holding an apple
i mean her
image presentation is so
hackneyed that i think
that's probably got a lot of mp's backs
up and thirdly you know she hasn't
really said
enough
if you looked at her campaign video with
that kind of strange eye-catching
movement that they did and and
her the key points were so
compared to everybody else they were so
weak it was just like you know low taxes
great opportunities lovely britain now
everybody has said that but some people
have said it in a much more lurid way
do you agree with that henry do you
think uh performance has been weak list
trust
it certainly hasn't been as strong as
you'd expect the leading candidate for
the right to be given the relative power
of the right wing of the conservative
party in parliament you know as i said
they've probably got about 140 maybe
pushing 150 votes on a good day and
expect them to be able to feel that you
know very very strong candidate now
that's not to say she's a weak candidate
necessarily but it hasn't necessarily
been the the the dominant performance
we've hoped for i think one of the most
potent challenges really being being
thrown at her is that in some senses
there's a sense he's sort of just
laughing as margaret thatcher there's
all of these
whole callbacks and references to mrs t
now obviously it's a conservative
internal election lady thatcher is still
very popular there's a there's a degree
to which that is understandable but
fundamentally we're
decades on
from 1979 we're facing a completely
different set of problems and i think
there's a slight nervousness that maybe
there's she's always looking over her
shoulder at history and not being her
own woman and that partly also applies
to penny morgan there's this sense that
we don't really know what kind of
conservative penny mordant is you know
she she she has been in conservative
politics for quite a long time not
necessarily always at the top although
she was defense secretary and yet
compared to some of the other candidates
who for better or worse have quite
well-defined offerings you know what
they think about a lot of issues one of
the few things we thought we knew what
penny thought on she's been sort of
disowning and obfuscating and the rest
of it we don't really have any idea and
i think that this is one of the reasons
we need to have a full contest is
precisely so that all the candidates can
be put under the microscope and we
conservative party members can work out
what exactly it is we're being asked to
vote for let's take a quick look at the
telegraph and we read that lord frost is
uh appealing to kemi abedin not to to
withdraw from the the leadership race so
she can back list trust we of course
know that he's been very scathing about
penny borden zoe
well the thing is is that
you know harry's completely right at
some point the right have to pick their
candidate and say this is our candidate
there's absolutely no way they can field
multiple right-wing candidates and just
to collapse in disarray as somebody like
tom tougenhart
sails through
and the right is really really good at
being ruthless and really good at
chopping people down so
i think the i think if
basically the calculation they've got to
make is if
it ends up as penny morden versus rishi
sunak the spartans of the party are
going to
have a fit they're going they're really
going to have a fit even though
benny mordan is doing a really good
impression of a very social conservative
at the moment she is known for being on
the kind of liberal wing of the party
rishi sunak
certainly doesn't have a kind of
swivel-eyed bone in his body even though
i have issues with other of his views so
you know you're basically looking at a
complete defenestration of the
right-wing tendency that's dominated the
party and pushed through brexit and
basically ruled the roost since 2016
if you end up with sunak and mordent so
i would imagine that it's going to be
all guns blazing to whittle that right
wing candidate down to one from now till
sunday okay we shall see on that zoe and
henry for the moment thank you we are
going to take a break
coming up
we'll discuss how the expected record
heat this weekend is likely to put
pressure on the nhs stay with us
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me zoe williams and henry hill
welcome back to you too um let's have a
look at the
mirror headline there red hot alert um
amy dark sphere 40
degrees surge it's a scorcher it will be
henry
yeah i mean it sounds it definitely
sounds like it's going to be um
concerning or the emergency services in
the nhs which is always slightly weird
because normally you know we associate
these hot weather stories with being
generally good news they're associated
with your pictures of people at the park
and on the beach and all the rest of it
but the tone of some of the coverage and
i'm not i'm no expert so i would defer
to those who are is that genuinely uh
days which do top things like 40 and i
can't remember actually ever
encountering a 40 degree day in the uk
do pose um serious health challenges for
people and they need to be careful
yes we've never reached 40. that that
would be a record set if we did actually
reach those sorts of temperatures but
the the prediction is that you know
there is going to be fallout for the
vulnerable the the elderly and uh the
young
so
it's a
i mean basically we have really low as
we've almost established actually
we've got really low literacy around
temperature in this country precisely
because it's not that hot ever so you
get temperatures there was a suspected
temperature of 43 degrees coming and the
metro and the sun last week both had
pictures of people on the beach now you
could not go to the beach in 43 degrees
it would be in it would be unbearable
people would be taken to hospital but
because we just have no
awareness or history or hinterland with
these temperatures we have no clue what
that actually would feel like now most
people are kind of fine and you just
stay indoors and you put a wet towel
around your neck and you do all those
things that you do and you get your dog
a little coat the problem is that it is
actually
very dangerous for the for the elderly
and it and it's and it you get to the
point where your you know your cells
once they get too hot they're like
scrambled eggs once they scramble they
cannot describe scramble so a lot of
people are really
worried about elderly relatives they're
worried about you know really basic
stuff about how to keep people cool
and
that's what we're kind of contending
with while we have this kind of festive
hooray temp headlines
is is the a and e reality and the
reality of many households that it's
very hard to keep cool when you're
vulnerable already yeah and the uh
cabinet office minister kit malthouse
has said that a surge in demand for
health service uh was expected further
complicated by the fact that there
there's been a rise in covet cases henry
yeah absolutely i mean we're going to be
in a pretty sorry state if the uh annual
nhs winter crisis is now accompanied by
an annual nhs summer crisis as well um
and as you say again there has been this
rising covered cases now i think most
you know for most of the nation the the
pandemic does more or less feel like
it's over you know you go out and about
now you see relatively few people in
masks there aren't restrictions not many
people are isolating but again just like
with the temperature there is a subset
of the population of vulnerable people
for whom it is very much still a real
problem who are less able to go out who
are more worried about complications and
so they face a double whammy effectively
of still having their movements
restricted by kovid and then perhaps
being trapped in homes which are not
built for this sort of temperature
fundamentally british homes you know in
america and so on where they get this
deal you've got things like air
conditioning most british homes aren't
built like that and i think that if
summers like this are going to continue
sooner rather than later probably we're
going to have to have a sort of a more
important national debate about whether
or not we need to start adapting more
british residential properties
properties especially for this sort of
summer
yes i do uh wonder what the stats are
zoe but um
lots of people that i know inquiring
about air conditioning something that
years ago you wouldn't have dreamed of
installing in a residential property
well they i mean frankly it's the worst
idea ever this whole problem is caused
by climate change and all you're going
to do with a load of domestic air
conditioning is fuel climate change the
thing is you read a lot on twitter feeds
i spend my life on twitter with people
saying do this do that don't open your
windows do open your windows close your
blinds
the
the thing is
european architecture it with the kind
of very stone very thick stone walls is
built to withstand heat so that it's
quite cool even when it's baking outside
and american architecture is not built
to withstand it but it's built with
aircon we are in the worst of all
possible worlds where we're not built to
withstand heat because we never see it
but we're not built with any aircon
either because we never need it so
you know if we do have a national
conversation about what how to deal with
these extremes of temperature it needs
to be a conversation about the future it
cannot be a conversation about a 20th
century response to these temperatures
because then we're going to cast
ourselves back into the dark ages we
definitely do need to have the the
conversation though many people not able
to sleep at night at all zoe and henry
for the moment thank you so much